after a siren I live was highly
criticized for hiring comedian Shane
Gillis Lorne Michaels has changed his
mind and shame will not be joining the
cast this fall after several Clips
emerged up Shane using racial slurs
against Asians yeah here's what the show
spokesperson tells us they say we want
SNL to have a variety of voices and
points of view within the show and we
hired Shane on the strength of his
talent and as a comedian and his
impressive audition for SNL we were not
aware of his prior remarks that have
surfaced over the past few days the
language he used his offensive hurtful
and unacceptable we are sorry that we
did not see these clips earlier and that
our vetting process was not up to our
standard so Shane is surprised that he
now has to make a public statement about
this but he wrote on Twitter I'm a
comedian who was funny enough to get SNL
that can't be taken away we got there I
wanted an opportunity to prove myself at
SNL but I understand it would be too
much of a distraction a respect decision
they made I'm honestly grateful for the
opportunity I was always a MADtv guy
anyway several celebs have weighed in on
this including Sandro who was just
nominated for an Emmy for hosting SNL
last season she tweeted this morning
glad to see SNL decision not to
legitimize give a platform to purveyors
of racist homophobic content risks lazy
ass unoriginal a tad late vetting but
glad to see looking forward to watching
Chloe Fineman and my man Bowen yang
Congrats so Chloe and Boren are two the
new other two new hires the season and
Bowen is actually the first Asian
American SNL has hired
so having Shane joined as well wasn't
exactly the best look so similarly oh
who called it SNL before they fired
Shane has now treated I never wanted to
celebrate or take joy over the
misfortune of others but Shane Gillis
refused to show remorse for what was
very evidently hate speech I'm glad SNL
acted with authority and moral fiber now
let's back to congratulating Bowen and
Chloe and a former SNL cast member Rob
Schneider wrote this dear Shane is a
former SNL cast member I am sorry that
you had the misfortune of being a cast
member during this era of cultural
unforgiveness where comedic misfires are
subject to the intolerable Inquisition
of those who never risk bombing on stage
themselves she also mentioned too that
both see Moo in Andrew yang the Democrat
running for president who Shane made fun
of in a couple clips have offered to sit
down with Shane right and talk to them
about it right I mean this is boom
sandro for the wind pulses people make
mistakes how can we learn four things is
what is important to allow someone to
grow i know it's is not surprised he was
fired SNL did the right thing that
Christine says lol was literally taken
away from you like what that Shane says
in the statement
Kate says why was he hired in the first
place they don't vet people I like that
about SNL statement that they actually
admit they didn't see the stuff full of
bull bull so he'll know they knew all
about it they just were waiting yeah I
didn't think it was gonna be that big of
a deal but that's that's now it's really
been through this the past few years ago
past when it came out or really what
people start to really notice that they
didn't know black females on the cast
yeah it changed that so that's no that
seemed to be still behind the times a
little bit they don't seem to realize
what they do sometimes this is a strange
hire they got a problem yeah so now SNL
has a major problem because they throw
that out there and they will make a
massive push when Eddie Murphy hosts
right this season and if you go back and
watch the first five minutes of
delirious you will be horrified right
horrified so what are they trying to say
that's that's the that's the sort of
problem with putting parameters on what
somebody considers comedy and what
somebody else does not consider comedy
or what is offensive because there's no
rules on what actually is offensive and
then how do you celebrate the return of
Eddie Murphy is it that delirious was
long enough ago and that he apologized
for it or has had discussions about it
but this was almost too soon like it's
such a it's such a world that they've
created for themselves that they will
contradict that their own statement
before the years up right curses I
didn't even know this guy existed his
senseless comments have as much value as
he does don't give him the game he
doesn't deserve and it does seem like a
strange hire because he hasn't struck me
that he's a great no former no or even a
great comedian like I mean all these
comments that he made were just in like
off-the-cuff podcast like it's not part
of a great stand-up gig that he did yeah
I don't really seem to be funny like we
go back to this thing of you know he's a
community he's allowed to do these
things but when he said these comments
they weren't even really part of jokes
there's kind of what they do they
workshop material I mean before jokes
they were clever no but there they
weren't clever that's fine enough
commonly you may not find it funny but
this is what this is what comics do they
they tell a joke a thousand times before
you see it on Netflix you know what I
mean and in 15 different ways like
that's just it's just what it's just
what they do was it it wasn't funny was
it a great rap no it was just dumb like
the whole thing was just stupid the
problem was he was so arrogant with his
initial apology and even with even with
this you know the I was good enough to
get SNL you can never take that away
your your name will never be mentioned
in SNL right you'll never they will
never go down years to now the the cast
lists of all the season your name will
not appear like it was taken away from
you it was the exact thing that you said
they could not do they did so yeah why
he was appealing that's not on the first
plan I don't know so if Dave Chappelle
wants to host next week are they gonna
say no right yeah be interesting to see
yeah what do they do yeah it's a problem
it's a real big problem